foreign
[Music]
coming up on FYI the kids who are
fundraising to help people affected by
the earthquakes in turkey and Syria
and Thomas gets a backstage pass to the
biggest school concert in the world your
rehearsals have begun and it's
absolutely Electric
[Music]
hello we're going to start with an
update on the earthquakes that happened
in turkey and Syria yeah the situation
there is really serious but lots of help
is on the way
[Music]
the earthquakes destroyed countless
buildings in both countries leaving
thousands homeless and in freezing
conditions without food water and other
supplies in Syria alone up to 5.3
million people are homeless
sadly thousands have been injured or
lost their lives
however there are some incredible
stories of survival against the odds
including 11 year old Armin and 17 year
old Jose who survived the earthquake in
Syria
I wanted yesterday we felt an earthquake
my siblings and I were asleep my
siblings left and I remained asleep I
was on my bed as the earthquake was
getting stronger a while later when
earthquake started to fade I wanted to
go outside something was blocking the
door I didn't know how I could possibly
leave but I then opened the window and
jumped out of it I was out I was free we
slept in the car until we drove to my
grandmother's house in the morning they
made me think of jumping out the window
this is our house it fell on US during
the earthquake yesterday and people ran
away this whole building fell on us but
thank God we escaped unharmed our things
are gone our water and food everything
is gone now we're staying at the camp we
are cold with no clothes or food or
drink it was snowing and raining
yesterday and the whole family was
outside in the cold there's no heating
or clothing or anything our homes are
under the rubber
people died under the rubble
in Turkey these children are having to
live in a lorry cabin after their home
was destroyed
single home to live in even a shipping
container would do us children need
proper clothes too
Charities across the world have launched
appeals to help aid is being sent from
more than 65 countries including food
medicine shelter supplies as well as
specialist teams to help the rescue
effort
thousands of people from across the UK
have come together to help those
affected by the earthquake like in
Cheltenham where an aid collection was
organized by the town Syrian refugee
community at the Saint Thomas More
Church meditating clothes food and
everything we can we're trying to help
them trying our hardest to help them and
hopefully we are doing the best but due
to our backlogging physical donations
reaching the affected areas it's now
being advised to donate money
so people in communities have been
raising funds in lots of different ways
like 60 year old Tabitha and 10 year old
Matilda we have been raising money for
the children in the earthquake in Syria
and Turkey by collecting litter in our
local area
Lara and Gem's extended family live in
the hate province in Turkey an area that
has been terribly affected by the
earthquakes their cousin has lost our
home in gaziantep which was at the
center of the earthquake Lara and Gem
did a sponsored eight-mile walk with
their parents to help raise over a
thousand pounds for those affected
and we're joined by 11 year old Ibrahim
who's also been fundraising hi Abrahim
welcome to FYI
so what have you been doing to help
turkey and Syria I did a 5k sponsored
one lots of people have sponsored me and
I think I've raised over seven thousand
pound now wow that's a lot of money and
5K is amazing so what made you want to
help out in this way so I've seen a lot
of footage of the earthquakes on the
news and in pictures in the newspapers
and I thought I must I thought I'm a bit
good at running and I could help people
with like some of my talents lots of
people came to support me including my
teachers my my family so obviously you
raised a lot of money but how do you
feel it went what was it like were the
first two laps okay we were out of
breath on the last one and the last lap
was like the hardest life I had to push
well you've done an amazing job raising
money thank you so much for joining us
thank you for letting me talk to you
guys surprise bye
check out this incredible sand
installation that's been made by Indian
artist sudashan patmike the sculpture
has the words join hands to save the
earthquake victims and is in tribute to
those affected in turkey and Syria
[Music]
there's more political drama as
Scotland's first Minister Nicola
sturgeon resigns unexpectedly the first
message of Scotland is in my admittedly
biased opinion the very best job in the
world
it is a privilege Beyond major
however since my very first moments in
the job
I have believed that part of serving
well would be to know almost
instinctively when the time is right to
make way for someone else but who is
Nicola sturgeon and why is this a
massive deal we've been investigating
for the last eight years Nicholas
sturgeon has been in charge of the
Scottish government it has the power to
make its own decisions on things like
education and public services such as
policing and the Health Service
Nicholas sturgeon was also the leader of
the political party the SNP which wants
Scotland to be completely independent of
the rest of the UK
a public vote known as a referendum was
held in 2014 and whether Scotland should
become independent but a majority voted
in favor of staying part of the UK
[Music]
we've seen many political leaders come
and go over the past year for many
different reasons the first Minister's
decision to resign is simply she says to
step down and make way for someone else
the U.S military is trying to solve the
mystery around these three UFOs
unidentified flying objects that have
been shot down from the skies above
America in the past few days but what
are these UFOs and who's behind them we
checked it out
there have now been four objects shot
down from U.S Skies this month the first
one was thought to be a spy balloon sent
by China and was flying high above the
American Coast although the Chinese
government has strongly denied this
countries have long used all kinds of
ways to spawn each other from secret
agents to satellites in space drones but
I didn't know balloons was a thing it's
usually to find out information about
the other country's plans for its
military and government although it's
illegal and no one likes being spied on
but the U.S military is still not sure
exactly what these objects are while
some are saying they are spy balloons
others say they are simply weather
devices but one senior American Army
official even says we can't rule them
out from being aliens crazy
[Music]
have you heard this scientists are
apparently working on reincarnating the
long extinct woolly mammoth apparently
they're planning on using recovered
genetic material from extinct specimens
to create the creature by 2027 but is
this fact or fake news find out later
[Music]
so less than a week after making history
for being the biggest Grammy Award
winner ever Beyonce picked up another
two Awards the best International artist
and best International song at the Brits
the British Awards celebrating popular
music
but it wasn't just Beyonce who stole the
show Harry Styles was Center Stage for
winning all four of the awards he was
nominated for and he made Joseph thank
his mom
but the Brits wasn't the only massive
music event that just happened Thomas
went behind the scenes at the Young
Voices concert the biggest school choir
concert in the world to meet some of the
future superstars
hey guys I'm at the O2 Arena and in a
few hours thousands of these pupils from
across the country are going to be
singing to support Children's Mental
Health
Young Voices is the largest school choir
concert in the world and this year is
the biggest tour to date
held at 27 venues across the country
each night up to 9 000 children perform
as a single choir with a live bands were
sold out audience of family and friends
while rehearsals have begun and
[Music]
[Applause]
it
what are you most excited about today
probably you singing with my friends
watching the incredible musicians it's
really fascinating with all the
instruments there does music mean a lot
to your school yes we're into singing a
lot and some of us play instruments I
certainly do the singing is a lot of fun
it's really nerve-wracking I just think
that music overall is just a great thing
to do the Young Voices songs this year
are great songs how does music make you
feel
um it makes me feel free so I feel like
I can express my emotions and it's
really easy to express myself through
music
[Music]
today good day
this year the tour has a star appearance
each night singer Heather small will
perform a hit song Proud with the Young
Voices quiet and it will be released as
a single to raise awareness and money
for the UK's Children's Mental Health
charity best to be
foreign
it's been amazing to be here and see so
many pupils coming together and singing
for such a brilliant cause
to you guys
[Music]
so did you think this story about
scientists reincarnating The Woolly
Mammoth was fake or fat well it's fact a
team of scientists are working on
genetically creating a creature that
will walk look and sound like the woolly
mammoth if they're successful the
reintroduction of a genetically created
Mammoth into the Arctic could provide
ecological and climate benefits
[Music]
time
Sky Brown has become Great Britain's
first skateboarding world champion at
the age of 14. Sky won Gold and Park
skateboarding at the world championships
in Sharjah United Arab Emirates with a
best score of 90.83 from her three runs
although Sky lives in America she has a
dual Japanese British citizenship and
chose to represent cgb she became Great
Britain's youngest Olympic medal winner
of all time when she won bronze at the
Tokyo 2020 games
[Music]
if you have a story you want to report
on for FYI get in touch via our webpage
or even better get your teacher to set
up an FYI News school but your school
members get a chance to report for us
and we will even help you film your
story you can watch and discuss all the
latest episodes and get on the program
with your views and reports head to our
webpage at first.news forward slash FYI
so can you believe it February 24th
marks one year since Russia launched an
invasion of Ukraine despite Russia's
Invasion being widely condemned by most
countries with pressures to end the war
from most world leaders Russia's
President Putin refuses to give in in
our next episode of FYI Scarlett has a
special investigation on how this war
affected millions of children
this is the story of what it's really
like to experience War Through The Eyes
of a child
their first hand account of what war is
like for them in Ukraine
well when I hear playing all there is a
loud sound I always get under the bed
how it felt to Run for Cover as the
world around them changed overnight
I bring all of my toys into basement and
I played with them I was just feeling
really sick
oh yeah tummy ache and was it from all
the stress of what was going on around
you yes
how children who came to the UK to be
safe still have a lot to deal with like
having to find a new place to live
Daniel are you sad about having to leave
your host family yes because we have big
plays we have we are very close to my
school
and how this Refugee risks going back to
a war zone
just to hug her parents she left behind
I'm so far away and even if I really
really wanted to help them it's just not
possible like I can't do anything
[Music]
so next time we'll be bringing you the
story of Ukraine's children of War
that's FYI investigates on Sky Kids On
Demand and Sky News
thanks for watching this week and don't
forget for more info about all the
stories we cover head to our webpage
first.new FYI bye
[Music]